c'est la beauté justement de la météo
imprévisible
on a commencé à marcher sur le lac et en
avant
au soleil pas de bac c'est super calme
filles en l'espace de 15 minutes
on s'y retrouve et que la plus belle des
lumières
si complètement magique malgré qu'on est
à la recherche de fonte quand je
cherchais à voir la vie on a déjà tout
le spectacle qui est à l'oeuvre devant
nous
[Musique]
cain qui ont réussi à croiser un animal
qu'on croit son record et comme on
partage cette intimité de ce petit
moment le jeu si ça devient fou
complètement le talent est
je
j'essaie de capter ce que ce qu'on voit
pas on a une forme très riche au québec
on a une forme magnifique et les timides
par contre l erreur aussi et à cesser de
l'homme m science mon rôle d'aller
chercher ce
[Musique]
m
on ne trouverait en rentrant dans une
forêt assez mature le dépiste d'orignal
très fraîche puis d'après ce que j'ai
analysé le duo daté de ce matin maximum
mon objectif c'est de trouver l'animal
mais dans le coût d'un orignal faut
faire très attention on veut surtout
pour aller le stresser j'aime découvrir
si des défections qui sont quand même
fraîcheur c'est un signe aussi à
regarder est ce que ça fait longtemps
qu'elles sont lorsque leurs gardes alors
en bonne santé aussi donc tout des
signes que moi j'analyse d'une une des
plus belle chance de ma vie justement
cette année j'ai prospecté un terrain
qui me semblent premier temps puis j'ai
trouvé des pistes semblaient fraîche et
on les a suivis
c'est comme ce qu'on a réussi à
rencontrer un bel orignal on le trouvera
il y avait encore ses bombes au panache
on avait un âge très abondants c'était
magnifique puis s'est couché au sol et
on a patienté
il sait faire recouvrir d'un match
complètement
on le laisser dans son paysage va plus
on est retourné
[Musique]
quand je t'en as présence d'un analyste
l'idée où s'arrête le temps donne est il
ya un échange de regards
je retourne l'instant de quelques
minutes à mon état sauvage comme si
j'étais partie intégrante de la nation
[Musique]
il ya de la curiosité
lui sa demande qu'est ce que je fais le
est ce qu'une voix un prédateur
c'est des moments souvent tu vas prendre
une photo d'eux mais que je dépose
l'appareil
en étant de vivre cet instant leur cet
échange les
plusieurs moments je me sentis comme
l'intrus dans la forêt maintenant je
sais à quel moment je dois quitter
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu comme opportunité
c'est assez
[Musique]
les grands moments que je passe à
l'atelier a créé les ambiances que je
recherche
ça me permet justement de les imaginer
imaginez qu est ce qui pour moi serait
la photo idéale
peut-être que mes tableaux moins
influencé à rester la petite dernière de
plus peut-être que j'ai compris que une
certaine lumière que je serais peut-être
capable d'aller chercher photographique
j'ai réussi à peindre avec ses couleurs
le
la création d'une oeuvre ou neuf qu'elle
soit belle
immensément belle ça a fini par faire
son temps pour moi j'ai besoin de plus
eu besoin qui a un sens j'ai besoin
qu'il ya une cause à enjeu et c'est là
que j'ai réalisé que mes réseaux sociaux
les plateformes doivent un certain
pouvoir de transmission d'informations
au delà de communiquer une belle émotion
je cherche beaucoup à communiquer un
enjeu maintenant les caribous c'est
c'est vraiment l'espèce qui est avec les
années d'une espèce préféré mon espèce
qui la plus emblématique qui représente
le mieux notre territoire ce qui m'a
toujours fasciné c'est de les voir en
groupe
l'esprit de hard
[Musique]
une sécurité qui se créeront ils vont
naturellement me laisser les approcher
naturellement s'approcher de moi l'art
de caribous de charlevoix c'est là que
je connais le plus les uns disent au fil
des années je les reconnais d'années on
eu des très mauvaises nouvelles par
rapport à leur nombre
on peut dire qu'ils ont à environ moins
de 20 restants j'ai réalisé en gardant
mes images que s'il reste moins de 20 la
majorité des individus que je
connaissais que je photographie depuis
des années sont probablement morts
je savais quelque part en moi que les
images que j'étais en train de prendre
serait un moment donné des documents
d'archivés je savais qu'un jour le
caribou serait en déclin puis
probablement que cet arbuste reporter
disparaître comme on a vu avec l'art de
vendre donc j'avais cette pensée
l'embardée moi mais j'aurais jamais
pensé que ce soit l'année d'après jamais
je vois ici dans 10 ans 15 ans
[Musique]
car qu'on apprend un peu sur l'habitat
du caribou
c'est là que l'on réalise que l'activité
humaine et causes principales à cela son
déclin
[Musique]
ce que j'espère avec mu image s'est
donné une petite étincelle de passion
aux gens pour qu'ils puissent aller eux
aussi s'approprier leur territoire
[Musique]
je connais personne qui ait connu la
fondent le territoire et qui s'en est
attaché puis qui qui souhaitent le
détruire si toutes ces micro contact qui
fait qu' on développe un lien une
relation avec notre territoire une
relation avec la forme qui doit
inévitablement porter vers sa protection
[Musique]